♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
President Biden was set
to discuss
his infrastructure
proposal today
with the top
Republican negotiator,
who I think is Joe Manchin?
In an op-ed yesterday,
Democratic Senator Joe Manchin
announced that he
would be voting
against a new voting rights bill
and reiterated his support
for the filibuster.
So, when I say he's Democratic,
that's just like
the party he's in.
Wyoming Congresswoman Liz Cheney
said, in a new interview,
that former President Trump's
incitement
of the January attack
on the Capitol is
"the most dangerous thing
a president has done."
Previously, it was go to a play.
[ Laughter ]
So, I'm glad
Scollins didn't change
[ Laughter ]
after a week off.
And he spent the whole week
in sensitivity training.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump's
daughter-in-law Lara Trump
announced, over the weekend,
that she will not run
for a Senate seat
in North Carolina,
due to her young children,
because she's seen firsthand
what happens when you neglect
Trump children.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump's blog
shut down permanently last week.
Oh, come on, you're not supposed
to shut down blogs.
You're supposed
to slowly stop posting,
'til you forget you have one.
Then, a year later,
you do one of those,
"Hey, guys, sorry I haven't
updated in a while" posts,
even though literally
no one's been asking
and no one could care less.
A spokesperson for British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson
recently announced
that he married his fiancée
in a small, private ceremony.
Just what the world needed --
another, less effective,
Johnson & Johnson.
[ Laughter ]
Today was former Vice President
Mike Pence's 62nd birthday,
despite Donald Trump's
best efforts.
Former Vice President
Mike Punce recent--
"Punce."
[ Laughter ]
I got it right
the previous joke.
-Yeah, yeah, you had it.
-So like I know what it is.
[ Laughter ]
You guys remember this punce?
["putz"]
[ Laughter ]
Former Vice President Mike Pence
recently spoke
at a Lincoln-Reagan Dinner
in New Hampshire
about the January attack
on the Capitol.
He didn't intend to,
but that's just
how flashbacks work.
Officials in Los Angeles County
are reportedly set to vote soon
on a law that prohibits
feeding peacocks
and make it punishable
by up to a $1,000 fine
or six months in jail.
Incidentally, "feeding the
peacock" is also what I call
making 200 shows a year.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, and she has an appetite!
A 30-year-old woman in Texas
was arrested
for trespassing recently,
after she allegedly posed
as her 13-year-old daughter
and spent the day at her school.
Damn, lady, why didn't you just
enjoy high school
when you were there?
Wait, oh, so she's 30.
Her daughter's 13.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I see.
Enjoy yourself.
And, finally, Amazon
CEO Jeff Bezos announced today,
in an Instagram post,
that he and his brother will be
on the first crew space flight
of his private rocket company
later this year.
If he wants to see space
so badly,
he should just open one
of his packages.
♪♪
President Biden leaves tomorrow
on his first foreign trip
since taking office
and, like all 78-year-old men,
that means he's already
at the airport.
[ Laughter ]
Vice President Kamala Harris
addressed potential migrants
in Guatemala during a news
conference yesterday and said,
"Do not come.
Do not come."
Wow, it's like she
read directly
from the Statue of Liberty.
Wait. I swear to God
it used to be there.
[ Laughter ]
New York Mayor Bill de Blasio
announced he's planning
a concert in Central Park
later this summer to celebrate
the reopening of the city
after the pandemic and this,
this is the guy you want
planning your concerts.
It's going to be that band
from the Viagra commercial,
[ Laughter ]
then, a Jimmy Buffett cover band
called Jimmy Buffet.
Then, at 8:00 pm,
everybody, out of the park
or the cops move in!
[ Laughter ]
CNN yesterday obtained the audio
of a 2019 phone call made
by former President Trump's
attorney Rudy Giuliani,
in which Giuliani pressured
a Ukrainian official
to announce an investigation
into possible corruption
by then-presidential candidate
Joe Biden, but,
it's actually not a slam dunk
for prosecutors.
See if you can tell why.
-I kind of think that this
could be a good thing
for having a much --
a much better relationship,
where we really
understand each other.
[ Beep ]
-Thank you for calling
the Long Island Aquarium.
-See? That's the problem.
-Your call is very
important to us.
[ Laughter ]
-Amazon's website was
temporarily down this morning,
due to an issue with their cloud
computing services provider,
but don't worry,
I'm sure that flight
into outer space next month
will go great.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Representative
Marjorie Taylor Greene on Friday
sent a letter to President Biden
that demanded he launch
an investigation
into Dr. Anthony Fauci
and provide answers
by June 31st,
a date that does not exist.
Which is surprising,
considering the last thing
I would've expected her to do
is extend Pride Month.
Former President Trump is set
to go on a tour
with former Fox News host
Bill O'Reilly later this year.
Oh, better lock up
your daughters.
Seriously, though,
it's probably best if you do.
You know, just 'til they're
out of town.
The owner of a pub in England
recently discovered
a time capsule from the 1970s
hidden in the walls of the bar.
Locals are fascinated
because they've never seen
anything that new.
Nathan's Famous yesterday
began offering meatless hot dogs
and, for what it's worth,
it took Joey Chestnut
50 dogs before he noticed.
[ Laughter ]
So, pretty good.
The world's largest
Harry Potter flagship store
recently opened in New York,
which displays over 1,000 props
from the movie series,
or -- and hear me out --
it's a hardware store.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, in a new interview,
sexual health expert Dr. Ruth
said that 90-year-olds
should still have sex,
if they have a good partner,
but added,
"If you don't have a partner,
they should satisfy themselves,"
so, now,
if you hear Grandpa
had a stroke,
maybe it's good news.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I'm not going to name
the guy who wrote that,
but, if you watch this show,
you know who it is.
[ Laughter ]
Tank top!
Roots for the
New England Patriots.
[ Laughter ]
Favorite movie character is
Casey Affleck
from "Good Will Hunting."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
President Biden yesterday
ended infrastructure
negotiations
with Republican
Senator Shelley Moore Capito
and opened talks with another
group of GOP lawmakers,
led by Senator Bill Cassidy.
Dude, you can keep searching,
but you're not going to find
a reasonable group
of GOP senators.
You're like a woman who says,
"Maybe if I go
to a different
Buffalo Wild Wings,
I'll find a husband."
[ Laughter ]
During an interview this week
with NBC news anchor
Lester Holt,
Vice President Kamala Harris
defended
the migrant situation
at the southern "bordah" --
border -- excuse me --
and said,
"There's not going to be
a quick fix."
I don't know, it seemed like
you had one the other day.
-Do not come.
Do not come.
-According to a recent poll,
Brooklyn Borough President
Eric Adams leads the field
in the New York
mayoral Democratic primary,
ahead of former presidential
hopeful Andrew Yang.
Said Yang, "What the hell
is Brooklyn?"
[ Laughter ]
Right-wing cable channel Newsmax
reportedly turned down
Florida Congressman Matt Gaetz
earlier this year,
after he approached them
about a job.
But if you knew what kind of job
he was asking for,
you'd turn him down, too.
[ Laughter ]
Federal prosecutors recently
arrested a Pennsylvania man
who allegedly posed
as former President Trump
to collect funds for a fake
reelection organization,
but instead used the money
for personal expenses.
What did they charge him with,
plagiarism?
[ Laughter ]
Starbucks announced yesterday
it's reintroducing
its 10-cent discount
for customers who bring
personal reusable cups.
Meanwhile, Dunkin' customers
can save a buck
if they just
hold out their hands.
[ Laughter ]
That's our Dunkin' customer?
Feel like that fights the joke.
[ Laughter ]
"Off to my business meeting!"
Ford yesterday unveiled
its new hybrid engine
compact pickup truck.
So if you love
driving a pickup,
but you care
about the environment,
I kind of just want
to learn more about you.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a travel agency
has announced plans to offer
a "Friends"-themed cruise
next year.
And nothing says
"I miss the '90s"
more than still using
a travel agent.
♪♪
While preparing to board
Air Force One yesterday
on his first foreign trip
since taking office,
President Biden was hit
in the neck by a flying cicada.
And get this, Biden still thinks
they can find common ground.
[ As Biden ]
Come on, man,
let's work together.
President Biden addressed
a group of U.S. troops
serving abroad
in the UK yesterday
and promised that he wouldn't
hold back in his meeting
next week with Russian
President Vladimir Putin.
So look out, Vladimir,
you're about to get called
Buster Brown.
Before leaving yesterday
for the UK, President Biden said
that the trip is all about
strengthening the alliance
with Europe.
That's never a good sign.
Anytime a couple goes on a trip
to strengthen their alliance,
you know they're about two weeks
away from a divorce.
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
met today
with British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson's wife, Carrie,
over tea.
Oh, man.
It's like those moms in the park
who only hang out
'cause their kids are friends.
"Oh, Joe -- Joe fell down.
Joe, get up.
You're fine, honey."
[ British Accent ] Boris.
Boris, what did you just put
in your mouth?
Spit it out, Boris.
After President Biden this week
told her he would end their
infrastructure negotiations,
Republican
Senator Shelley Moore Capito
said in an interview yesterday
that she was disappointed
in Biden's decision.
Said progressives,
"Disappointed in Biden?
Finally, some common ground."
Vice President Kamala Harris
invited every female senator
to a dinner next week
at her residence,
while Kyrsten Sinema
invited them to...
adult Quidditch?
And a midnight screening
of "Rocky Horror"?
France is reportedly
sending the U.S.
a replica statue of --
a replica Statue of Liberty,
excuse me,
nicknamed "The Little Sister,"
and it'll be the only foreigner
we let in this year.
The final episode
of the reality show
"Keeping Up with the
Kardashians" aired tonight
and, if you've never seen
the show before,
trust me, you've kept up.
They're sisters
and they're rich.
Got it.
My wife loves that show.
I've never seen an episode.
I only hear it while she's
watching it on her phone
and I feel like I've heard this
a hundred times.
[ Crying ] "It is just really
hard having sisters."
And finally,
Mattel announced today
that it will launch a new
line of Barbies
that are made
from recycled plastic,
called Barbie Loves the Ocean.
Which a great idea.
I just wish they'd recycled it
a little bit more.
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]